to show you how to run a notebook on
Google collab and then save it to your
GitHub
so here's my notebook first of all I
want to show you that I'm installing
kaleido and this is something that will
allow you to save your images from
plotly that were interactive but if you
save them on GitHub it's not going to
work they're just not going to show up
so first what you need to do is you need
to run this where you install collado
and then you have to restart the runtime
so you have to go to runtime and then
here restart runtime
yes
now that you've done it you don't need
to press this button again you can start
going down to the next cell
and here we are going to load the data
explore what the day looks like then
we're going to generate a principal
component analysis image now this is an
interactive plotly
visualization but down here you can see
that we can use the IPython display
image package where we will generate a
PNG image and show it in the cell
so now this is an image that first of
all you can save to your computer but
also when you save this to GitHub it's
going to come up in your notebook so
let's do this right here you go to file
and go to save a copy in
GitHub
now here you might see
different repositories that you might be
a part of and so instead you can
actually
go back to your GitHub
and you can see that I want to change
this right because I don't want to save
it to my company I want to save it to my
private Repository
I'm going to go back
and I'm going to do cancel
and then I'm going to change this to my
account that I use
with that GitHub so I'm going to open
the same one if you don't have access
you will request access so let me share
this
I'm going to just uh
make sure that I share
okay and I'm going to go down to this
image and make sure that it's here
and now I can save it to GitHub
and now it's connected to my repository
Ilia Brodsky bioinformatics
list the file path and I can do an
optional
commit message which I don't need to do
and now it's going to create a copy so
here is my GitHub profile
I can reload it
and you can see now
this is
appearing in this public repository now
you have to make sure that the
repository is public and let's scroll
down now you can see this image right
here
right so that's a nice way to make sure
that all of your images are visible
including this image down here after
feature selection
now how do I know that my repository is
public and go back to my profile
and here you can see repositories
and here you will see that it is public
and whether you have anything inside so
if I go to this one
you should see
this file inside and that's how you know
that it is available in public
on your GitHub repository
that's all